hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast live in 30 days and NGS
workflow for your lab presented by econ
PhD product director at kiya Jen I'm
sorry grenman of lab roots and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by kaya Jen for more
information about our sponsor please
visit wkyt.com before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located a promotional board
at the bottom center of your screen or
use the ask a question box to let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming dr. calm I
will now turn the presentation over to
her
oh sorry and thank you everyone for
taking time to join this webinar today
my name is G Kong and I work as a
product director occasion today I would
like to use the next 30 minutes to
introduce to you the gene reader system
which is a complete NGS workflow
designed specifically for your
laboratory and can help you go live in
just 30 days
I have some simple agenda items today
first I would like to present to you
some latest updates we made to the June
reader system and next I'd like to
introduce to you from the new panels
that would have launched
if you look at laboratory
implementations of NGS workflow it is
typically a lengthy and challenging
process a laboratory has to put together
a complex workflow assembled from
products from various vendors and then
take the time and effort to optimize the
whole system and troubleshoot any
potential hurdles and this process
typically takes nine to twelve months
from the initial acquisition of the
components to going live and this is
where we develop the generative system
to address the issue because it's not
just a sequencer but instead of complete
system going from DNA and RNA extraction
all the ways to be data analysis and
interpretation we bring to you in
addition to the gene reader sequencer
itself all the ancillary instruments to
automate the entire process in addition
we have other instruments that can help
you implement quality control every step
we also launched together with a gene
reader a gene read assistant app on the
iPad to help you not only track the
systems track the workflow and the
samples but also ensure a complete full
sample custody of the entire workflow
and last but not least we also have a
software called Jing relink
which enables bi-directional
communication with the lymph system so
that you can integrate very easily your
NGS workflow and the results with the
rest of the lymph system data
the ultimate goal of any NGS test is to
get add a simple and customized report
and this is what you would get for the
gene reader system it is simple it is
completely actionable and it's fact a
fact with comprehensive data and this is
because we have a the most comprehensive
and a broad sum of knowledge base behind
the kaijin by informatics horsepower and
this is not a database that's including
over 30 various sources and we have
mined over 30,000 publications sequenced
over a million genomes and this database
is continuously updated by obscuration
food made up of over 200 and these and
PhD
if you look at the sequencer itself we
implement sequencing by synthesis
technology which is automated on the
gene reader platform itself allows
reflow cells to the user simultaneously
or independently course run or run in a
staggered fashion the data output is
over to the ecru flow cell with six cake
in total a real instant go up 250 base
pairs it automatically generates a fast
to file that can be transferred directly
for secondary analysis
for target enrichment library
preparations we implement the what we
call the Umi or unique molecular indices
of strategy on the left hand side you
can see in the conventional targeted
sequencing way if you identify a rare
variant you don't know if that's truly a
rare variant or possibly an error or
artifact introduced as part of the
workflow on the right hand side as you
can see before in the amplitude
amplification takes place we add a um I
or molecular barcode to each of the
original template strands thus allowing
us to trace the reading results back to
the original template and as such if a
variant is identified if we will be able
to identify that as either a true
variance in which case all attacks all
types of reads that containing that
original tag would share the same
variance or is possibly artifact that's
not shared amongst others other reads so
this allows us to dramatically enhance
the accuracy of the sequencing and
interpretation
in addition we also implemented a
deamination process as part of our DNA
extraction and processing processing
steps there are a lot of publications in
the literature describing cytosine
deaminase ins as a major contributor for
success sequencing noise and artifacts
in the NGS borer flow and we have
introduced a new ng digest as a part of
a chat and procedure with a gene read
ESPYs we make it to eliminate this
artifact
as a result as you can see here when we
align the cue scores for from the gene
reader reads you see the cluster around
the low 30s which is standard for
industry for Amazon based sequencing
results in the inner shoes when we
introduce these steps such as um eyes
and SP correction you will see that the
sequencing reads Q score dramatically
increases to over 60 drastically
eliminating almost all of the artifacts
and arrows introduced as part of the NGS
workflow so this allows us to provide a
complete NGS workflow that can maximal
maximize your frequency accuracy and
efficiency and minimize any potential
artifact
next I would like to introduce to you
some the new generator panels that we
have recently launched
first I would like to introduce to you a
kayak bracha 1/2 panel
Raja as you know are two genes that are
most commonly known as inheritance risk
factors for breast and ovarian cancers
however recent literature as well as
targeted therapies also suggest there
are a lot of somatic mutations in both
raka 1 and 2 genes that can lead to a
progression of ovarian and breast
cancers and that as such is important to
understand these somatic mutations as
well as the inherited one so for this
panel we have specifically tested to
perform well on SPE samples at down to 5
percent sensitivity threshold as you can
see here in the test sample that we
apply to the set to the panel were able
to achieve 100% sensitivity accuracy as
of PPD
the interpretation software that we call
hygienic clinical interpret interpret
provides clear insight into the
significance of any variant funsies in
this example you can see vast majority
of the bracha
one and two variants identified are
marked as screen I eat benign whereas
there's one that's caught out that's
highlighted in red is identified as
pathogenic and if you click on that one
you will see that the database
identifies the source of the variants
identifies the frequency of the mutation
as well as any clinical significance of
that variant any approved therapies
ongoing active clinical trials as well
as guideline information is also
provided so the user can have all the
relevant actionable information right in
the same screen
let's we also recently launched a lung
cancer all-in-one acid this is a
comprehensive NGS workflow that combines
the beauty of PCR immunohistochemistry
fish and microarray to identify not only
in cells and mutations but also copy
number variants as well as common
fusions that take place in lung cancer
so once I usually identify all types of
important genetic variants with just one
easy workflow
in this data set you can see that we can
identify all types of variants add down
to 5% in effort TV samples and less than
1% in liquid biopsies with a specificity
of greater than 90%
for copy number variant identifications
we also tested it in the number of cell
lines in addition to FFPE samples and as
you can see here were able to achieve
100% correct identification of the true
positive
for FFPE samples similarly we're also
able to identify 100% of the correct
positives and none of the false
positives achieving 100% positive
predictive values and PPA and
specificities
also comes back to the study a liquid
biopsy samples and as you can see here
we are able to also identify the
deletions and as well as mutations in
liquid biopsy samples
yeah and when we expanded a study to
look at below 1% leo frequencies you can
see that we're able to achieve a very
high level of PPV to be a and
specificity at down 2.6% and the
efficiency
recently we also launched a minor
leukemia panel that covers all the
important diseases within NPN MDS and
AML and this panel will allow you to
identify all the critical and actionable
variants including cancers and we'll be
able to share a lot new exciting data on
this panel very soon
so in summary what I have shared with
you today are the latest updates on the
gene reader system we're able to improve
the performance of the overall system at
every step of the workflow to achieve a
superior sequencing result also we have
launched a new bra cap channel launch
answered panel and a CMOS panel to add
to our original PN cancer hospital I
also I didn't present data here but I
also want to stress that we also have
custom channel open and we can design
any panel of interest for you so with
that I'd like to thank lab rules and
sorry for hosting the webinar and hand
it over back to her for any questions
Thank You dr. Khan for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is what is the workflow
with this workflow do I still need a
bioinformatician on staff to be able to
analyze it and interpret the data the
short answer is no we designed the
system so that it specifically allows
our team of curators and the BI
informaticians
to work behind the scenes on behalf of
our customers so you won't having access
to the latest and greatest a
comprehensive database as well as any
updated data on the on a real-time basis
that's eliminating the need for a
full-time specialized by limitation
obviously there still needs to be some
training to gain for minerality with the
amount systems and the interpretation
software but that can be done on an
individual customer basis and one does
not need a specialized training to do
that
great wonderful next question is how
often is your database updated and
through what mechanism
that's a great question our database is
updated in ongoing on a weekly if not
daily basis this is done through two
different ones the one is we have
automated data mining that continuously
monitor any changes in for example
publication and any updates in clinical
trial sites incorporate that into the
database but more importantly we also
have a team of curators for MDS and PhDs
who manually read not only the abstracts
but also the actual content of any
publication and and interpret and
incorporate them into the database so
that is happening on an ongoing basis
and anytime you query the database which
is website based you will gain access to
the latest information
thank you how does the multiple flow
cell configuration work
so our system is the only one in
industry that offers a three flow cell
configuration this allows you to run
them either individually simultaneously
or in a staggered fashion so you could
decide to run all three that happen to
have a lot of samples today or you could
say I didn't want to run one to save
sequencing reagents and speed up the
process you could also run one slow cell
today and add another one or two
tomorrow that's allowing you to process
samples as they come in and not having
to wait to batch them
and how many samples can you process
that's a good question it obviously
depends on the size of the sample and
the sequencing depth that you would like
to achieve using the hotspot pan-cancer
panel as an example you could run up to
16 samples per flow cell so that is 48
samples maximum in the in the particular
run but lung cancer panel you can run 12
samples per flow cell so that is up to
36 per run so very much depends on the
panel
thank you for that answer where can I
find more information on this system can
I see a demo absolutely if you'd like to
find out more information on the website
please go to WWE NGS comm that will take
you to the dedicated gene reader site
that where you can find a lot of
information you can also obviously reach
out to your local college and
Representatives who can provide you with
any information you may request and feel
free to reach out to myself as well my
email address is my first claims on my
last thing I am calm and I'll direct you
right on as well wonderful thank you
our next question is who is tested or
purchased the system
great question our system have achieved
over 100 customers globally we have a
lot of customers all over the world
actually in Europe in Asia and
especially in the US as well to give you
a few examples the growing skew was the
very first one to test the system we
also have implemented the workflow at
Cornell Dartmouth as well as a number of
community-based hospital network
okay we have time for one more question
I see there are three pieces of
instrument in the pictures besides the
gene reader what are the other two
pieces do you have to buy them together
okay that's a great question so
obviously besides the gene reader
sequencer itself you also see two other
boxes one of them is called the kaya
cube which is essentially a robot that
helps you process of extraction as well
as library library preparation and it
also has many other functionalities and
you can use the independence of the NGS
workflow for any type of extraction and
many protocols
it can handle DNA RNA as well as
proteins and this is a system that we
have launched a number of years ago and
has globally over 8,000 of them
installed so it really is a very robust
robot students because that you can you
can easily acquire and this can be used
independent of the NGS workflow we have
another box that's called the giri di
field it is specifically dedicated for
the clone or amplification steps of the
workflow this is a necessary step right
before you take it onto the sequencer to
allow maximum amplification of the
template strands so this is a system
that goes together with a dream reader
and it is a library preparation
automation platform so we offer the gene
reader as a complete engine Buffalo and
encourage that the customers get the
entire system so that you have one
vendor and one protocol and one workflow
I would like to once again thank dr.
Kong for her presentation I would also
like to thank AIA Jen for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I would like to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through July of
2018
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know that when this cat
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye